right now the United States energy
system puts about 5 billion tons of
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere every
year it's just too much it exceeds the
capacity of the earth to absorb it again
and it's changing the climate of the
planet trick is we have to try and keep
from putting that carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere without giving up the energy
that we all love the idea is let's try
and catch the carbon dioxide before we
dump it up into the atmosphere
[Music]
at this government lab in California
scientists are working on a technology
called carbon capture the goal is to
catch the co2 spewing out of power
plants before it goes into the air and
then store that co2 safely underground
this technology is a reality it's in use
at a handful of power plants around the
world but it's still too expensive and
inefficient to make a real difference
john varicella and his team may have
found a way to change that so now you're
gonna show me the capsules kind of give
a little swirl and you'll kind of
agitate them up and you'll see that
they're a bunch of little capsules in
there and you can grab some and sort of
throw them it's like umm tobiko yeah top
of your sushi probably don't want to eat
these but yeah we're trying to improve
the way that we absorb and capture
carbon we do that using a small micro
capsule design so the idea is that we
take a fluid that will absorb co2 and we
wrap it in a shell that's a polymer it's
what you would have is these capsules in
the exhaust stack and they're being
contacted by the exhaust of the coal
plant or whatever it is
the co2 will pass through the polymer
shell to be absorbed by that liquid core
and so the co2 stays inside the cops
exactly capturing yep
when we started to look at how to
capture carbon dioxide and wouldn't
think about what are the problems with
the existing processes and what can we
do to make them better there's been
success at capturing carbon dioxide from
power plants and from industry for the
moment though it's still too expensive
the problem with carbon capture as it
exists today is that it takes a lot of
energy to make the process work which
makes it expensive that's where the
capsules come in they make the process
faster more efficient and therefore
cheaper speeding up the process is often
about surface area and that's the trick
that we do with the capsules by forcing
them to be real tiny droplets they now
contact an enormous amount of surface
area and absorb the gas faster so we
save energy and we say expense using
this new process we're gonna do a little
demonstration this is just a carbonated
drink and so what we're gonna do is pour
some of this in there and we'll add some
capsules and we're going to see them
actually absorb the co2 out of this soda
when they absorb the co2 they're gonna
go through a pH swing and they're gonna
change from this dark blue to a yellow
so now so now they're blue so you can
see that they're getting lighter yeah
there's a definite yellow tint so now
all that co2 is inside each tiny tiny
individual capsule exactly and you've
got flat soda too
even if every power plant in the world
started using these capsules tomorrow it
still wouldn't be a complete solution to
climate change
capsules aren't really practical in cars
for example because they would add too
much weight but right now capturing
carbon from fossil fuel power plants is
probably our best shot at slowing global
warming that is until we can switch to
cleaner ways of making energy the amount
of co2 that we're producing needs to be
dealt with this is a way to try to
tackle that John Duracell is gonna see
these things expand and be used and
he'll live long enough to see these
things actually change the climate of
the planet and that's really cool to
think about
you